how did you end up getting your stuck on
stage
at the time I was doing it I was just
doing like every day so I'm always like
weird it was a lot of girls at the show
they were and they were feeling the boy
like I would be rapping and I'd be like
on this corner but like a group of girls
and they'd be like rubbing me like
grabbing my dick and all that and doing
all you know just being creepy but then
I'll go on the other side of the
stations like 150 year old looking old
white lady she's doing the same thing
but she's going a little further than
everybody else so then she just pulled
the shirt up and started doing her thing
I kept rapping oh yeah I mean I I got to
do the show I mean I paid to do a job
and did you let her finish no no the
thing was it just got so crazy it just
was so [ __ ] up because you got to
think man there's a lot of guys at the
show too and they were like getting
smushed and smashed and they were
getting close to the closer to the I was
just saying the look of horror on it
oh